you said something that's why i hate
politics but you're in politics yeah
what do you hate about it what do you
love about it what can young people
start to understand about it yeah so
there's a there is a difference so i
work for a non-profit i mean prageru is
a non-profit so it's political but it's
not politics okay as a non-profit we
legally can't talk about candidates
bills legislation anything like that or
we would lose our non-profit
status right so we talk a lot about
values we talk about information we talk
about that kind of stuff not about
actual politicians and things like that
you know i get in trouble when i talk
about politicians sometimes so i have to
keep that stuff down below when we're on
the prageru platform but what i hate
about the politics is that it is so fake
all of it is so fake and what politics
does i don't know if you're familiar
with the the author abraham herbert but
he talks about politics turns people
into ciphers and that's what the
political system does is that a cipher
is someone who can no longer think for
themselves because the political party
has told them what to think exactly and
i am all for people being individuals in
the most
important sense first you get to a good
society like the left will talk about we
need to do things for the greater good
or for the good of society screw society
what is society society is a collection
of individuals if you make good
individuals then you will have a good
society so until you actually start
focusing on individual people and not
the party or the politics and this kind
of stuff then you won't have a good
society and you just have orgy sex
cocaine partners
you know so you have to focus on it in
congress yeah that's why we need people
like you in politics and the one and
only patriarchy people like you to help
people think
yeah it's hard i see it's hard because i
i don't want to be too vain but i'm i'm
very real i'm real i talk about what's
real and that's just that's why people
like you yes but that type of person
doesn't last in politics they want to
destroy people exactly when the
republicans want to destroy someone like
me but you don't need to last you come
you make your impact and then hopefully
it cultivates enough people around you
like look at the network that patrick is
doing the things he talks about it
doesn't have to be him the whole time it
has to be him who he's bringing and then
they it's kind of like a domino effect
[Music]